et on va plus loin avec jadimam
directeur du mensuel Afrique Magazine
bonjour Ziad bonsoir kit titres sur Côte
d'Ivoire le prochain arrive voilà
opération Grand Nord et sur Karim
Benzema et Sadio Mané les meilleurs du
monde à l'occasion de ce mondiale mais
qui n'y était pas bon on aurait pu
ajouter
de la rédaction de France 24 chroniqueur
international ici bonjour
ça va pas nous empêcher d'en parler
parce que oui le Maroc a donc inscrit
son nom dans l'histoire du football aux
côtés du Cameroun du Sénégal et du Ghana
trois seules équipes africaines avant
lui à avoir atteint les quarts de finale
les Marocains ont donc et les Espagnols
à l'issue de la séance de tir au but
c'est un énorme évènement sportif il y a
pour le football pour le Maroc et pour
tout le continent africain c'est un
énorme événement sportif d'abord parce
que c'est une fierté pour le Maroc on
sait qu'en ce moment les temps sont durs
un peu partout que des particules si on
prend le cas du Maroc et le problème de
sécheresse et les problèmes d'inflation
et donc que cette victoire portée par
par ces garçons apportent un espèce
d'énorme souffle d'optimisme et ce que
fait toujours la Coupe du monde ça cette
coupe du monde elle elle crée de
l'enthousiasme elle crée elle crée aussi
parfois des des drames parce que on perd
et que c'est une catastrophe mais là il
gagne ils inscrivent leur nom pour le
Maroc pour le Maghreb pour les pays
arabes faut pas oublier que cette Coupe
du Monde se joue au Qatar et donc il y a
une véritable un arabo centrisme une
arabo entre anthropie
on a vu j'ai vu sur mon twitter les
commentaires des télévisions arabes
c'est parti totalement Henri
c'est-à-dire que on est dans le coeur de
l'action et c'est aussi malgré tout une
malgré tout c'est aussi une victoire
africaine parce que là aussi grâce à
Twitter grâce au téléphone on a une
résonance et on voit à quel point
l'Afrique c'est identifié à cette équipe
après avoir petit à petit perdu les
autres mais voilà donc et puis il y a
cette idée aussi que
rapidement que
le foot est à l'image du monde
c'est-à-dire les rapports de puissance
changent ceux qui ont les meilleurs ne
sont pas forcément les meilleurs il y a
des nouveaux acteurs le Maroc la Corée
du Sud le Japon c'est des petits acteurs
mais ils sont à l'image de ce qui se
passe ailleurs dans le monde sur la
sphère économique sur la sphère
politique avec des acteurs mais aussi le
monde devient multipolaire voilà c'est
une forme de multipolarité qui
s'applique à la Coupe du monde et qui
est assez spectaculaire cette victoire
retient elle tient aussi à l'affiche du
match entre deux voisins au passé chargé
oui parce que si on parle de d'un monde
multipolaire ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait plusieurs ballons et on voit ce
que ça peut donner sur un sur un terrain
de foot non ce que vient de dire il y a
des tout à fait exact et moi j'aimerais
en tant que poil à gratter dire
malheureusement parce que si vous voulez
le fait que par exemple au Maroc tout le
monde se retrouve fédéré malgré les
difficultés malgré ce qu'on peut penser
du roi etc c'est quelque chose qui
finalement fédère alors peut-être tant
mieux parce que au fond je crois que
c'était François qui disait si les
hommes sont assez stupides pour se faire
la guerre bah autant qu'il le fasse avec
des objets qui n'explosent pas et c'est
le cas du ballon donc voilà peut-être ce
qu'on peut dire mais c'est vrai pour
revenir à votre question qui a il y a un
contentieux c'est un contentieux
d'origine coloniale puisque au fond
c'est l'Espagne qui en partant en
quelque sorte l'aide mais sans que ça
soit reconnu dans les dans les dans les
actes et surtout dans les traités ce
territoire du Sahara qu'on appelait
Sarah espagnol à la couronne marocaine
alors avec la question de l'Algérie qui
lors une de celui qui voudrait qui a
suscité un mouvement de résistance qui
ne feront Polisario pour que justement
ils ne tombent pas dans l'escarcelle ce
territoire dans l'escarcelle marocaine
le Maroc lui de fait considère qu'il
s'agit d'une province à part entière de
de son de Willy du royaume et à partir
de là vous avez quantité de de position
d'escarmous et surtout une diplomatie
marocaine qui va se dégager de cette de
cette situation de fait comme étant une
diplomatie qui veut qui va vouloir faire
pression sur justement les Européens
aussi bien les Espagnols mais on a vu ça
il y a quelques années avec les
mouvements migratoires qui faisaient
pression justement sur les enclaves
espagnoles de ceutaimédia parce qu'ils
ne partagent pas qu'une frontière
maritime mais également avec des
enclaves avec ces deux enclaves
espagnols et quand finalement le Maroc
le souhaite il stoppe et pardonnez-moi
de parler ainsi ce flux de migrants
parce que ce sont des gens quand même et
quand ils le souhaitent pas il ouvre ce
flux qui pose problème aux Européens
donc ça c'est une place que le Maroc a
tenu à prendre via l'opposition ou le
contexte anti-espagnol mais qui a quand
même une répercussion sur l'ensemble de
ce monde dont il est souhaité qu'il ne
soit pas unipolaire alors ça c'est pour
la trame de fond et puis au plan sportif
c'était tout de même l'Espagne
championne du monde trois fois
championne d'Europe qui se dressait un
devant les les Marocains aujourd'hui et
puis tout de même auréolé même s'ils
sont parcours en fin de poules a été un
peu plus difficile mais d'une victoire
quand même écras la fin de cette bu à
zéro face au Costa Rica c'est la seule
ils étaient grandissime favoris
tour très difficile malgré leur victoire
écrasante contre le Costa Rica qui
d'ailleurs par la suite c'est repris
donc je pense pas de façon le problème
c'est qu'on peut toujours analyser a
posteriori un match de foot c'est un
match de foot l'Espagne elle a un
palmarès elle est très très en haut dans
les classements le Maroc a un palmarès
mais il est beaucoup plus bas dans les
classements donc on est quand même dans
le registre de l'exploit et puis le fait
d'arriver en quart de finale dans le le
top 8 c'est quand même c'est quand même
assez impressionnant
bien sûr le contexte joue mais moi je
serai un petit peu moins j'allais dire
un peu moins tranchant là dessus c'est
que d'abord il y a des relations de
voisinage il y a des relations de
couronnes avec des échanges oui d'abord
le Maroc et l'Espagne sont face à face
ils se connaissent ils se pratiquent il
s'échangent vous prenez les avions entre
Casa rabat Malaga le sud de l'Espagne
Madrid un bateau etc donc il y a malgré
les difficultés liées à la question
migratoire malgré les difficultés liées
aux questions économiques il y a quand
même quelque chose qui les lie c'est
avec la France le pays le plus proche de
l'Union européenne et qui est à leur
frontière terrestre et maritime
ensuite je pense que je suis d'accord
avec toi il y a toujours une résonance
politique mais je pense que dans une
coupe du monde en fait les gens ils sont
hors résonance politique même français
dans le dans la symbolisation de la
fierté nationale et donc chef d'État pas
chef d'État c'est une autre discussion
je sais pas si vous vous rappelez
quand on a gagné la Coupe du monde en
France il y a 4 ans bon il y a pas eu un
effet spectaculairement pour Macron et
quand Chirac était sur le balcon c'était
pas non plus spectaculaire par contre si
vous rappelez en 98 on a sorti quelque
chose qui était black bombers qui
n'avait rien à voir avec le pouvoir ça
avait avoir avec la société française
donc je pense que le foot à cette
qualité de passer à travers ça pour
plutôt jouer sur les sentiments
nationaux avec du positif mais aussi du
négatif quand on vire quand on vire à
l'ultra-nationalisme quand on vit
à l'exacerbation des sentiments donc
c'est là que j'étais juste un tout petit
peu Gauthier un peu en désajuste puisque
tu parles de 98 effectivement c'est un
moment très intéressant mais qui à mon
sens quand on parle de fierté nationale
oui c'est vrai c'est indéniable mais je
pense qu'elle peut rester très ambiguë
sauvons-nous de ces drapeaux algériens
qui étaient des Champs-Élysées en 98 et
qui était la manifestation extrêmement
complexe d'un rapport à l'identité ou la
nation française pour des gens qui
disaient j'en suis mais j'en suis pas
complètement parce que quand on me dit
que j'en suis pas complètement je suis
bien obligé de reconnaître que j'ai des
difficultés donc je sors le drapeau
algérien mais je fête la victoire
française ne serait-ce que cet exemple
là et pour montrer que cette unanimisme
oui je suis d'accord
qu'il est quelque chose forcément de
façade et que ces problèmes politiques
ils sont pas très loin derrière à chaque
fois je parlais du politique au sens de
du rôle du de du pouvoir mais regardez
par exemple l'histoire de l'apparition
de la Palestine dans cette Coupe du
Monde c'est quand même très intéressant
Palestine et partout dans cette Coupe du
monde elle ne joue pas au foot elle a
pas d'équipe elle en a une mais elle est
pas qualifiée je suis même pas si oui je
crois qu'il me rappelle plus mais voilà
elle est portée par des gens qui sont
dans les stades et qui rappellent
l'existence donc on est c'est vrai on
peut être à la limite mais encore une
fois ça joue beaucoup sur la liberté sur
la nation sur l'identité le cas du Maroc
ou d'autres équipes africaines il y a
beaucoup d'expatriés dans ces équipes il
y a beaucoup de gens qui jouent en
Europe il y a beaucoup de gens qui
jouent dans les grands clubs mais ils
sont absorbés
il est pas le seul ils sont absorbés à
l'identité à ce moment-là la force de
l'identité dans la victoire ça les
intègre complètement dans la nation oui
donc ça n'en fait plus des citoyens moi
c'est ça qui me pose problème ça les
intègre
c'est dans un palmarès oui dans quelque
chose de fort qui est une fédération
mais les sentiments quand c'était Léo
Ferré qui disait la pensée commune est
une pensée oui la pensée mise en commun
d'une pensée commune peut-être le
sentiment national quand il est il vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure quand il fait
l'objet d'une simplification
nationaliste il supprime ce qu'il y a
derrière alors moi je veux bien mais ce
n'est aussi que du foot oui c'est à dire
que demain les réalités des uns et des
autres exactement prendront leur place
dans leur quotidien sont bien d'accord
alors justement ce n'est qu'une
compétition et ce n'était qu'un tour à
passer est-ce que d'après vous compte
tenu ce qu'ils ont démontré jusqu'à
présent ils ont quand même fini en tête
de leur groupe les Marocains sont
désormais des prétendants sérieux au
titre qu'il faut considérer comme tel
bah en tout cas ils ont une sacrée
défense ils ont du courage ils ont de la
résistance je ne sais pas exactement ce
qui se passe à l'heure où je vous parle
dans le match qui oppose de 0 pour le
Portugal face à la Suisse qui est donc
le prochain adversaire si jamais le
scénario ne change pas voilà un autre
match à forte dimension émotionnelle
entre le Maroc et le Portugal puisqu'on
est toujours dans la péninsule ibérique
on est toujours dans le voisinage
Cristiano Ronaldo qui ne joue pas
d'ailleurs qui ne joue pas match puni
pour sa réaction
mais voilà bon Cristiano Ronaldo est
très propre très proche du Maroc il
voyage tout le temps il a donc on va on
va toujours être dans cette espèce de
lien entre et puis on espère qu'ils
auront le plus loin possible après c'est
peut-être la France ou l'Angleterre
justement gaucher il faut se s'inquiéter
se méfier du on aurait tendance
évidemment à préférer le Maroc au
Portugal compte tenu du palmarès mais en
fait ce qu'on aurait tort de penser
ainsi on se souvient les Portugais
avaient battu quand même la France en
finale de son euro organisé en France
oui et puis alors là encore je vais
faire la mauvaise tête mais si vous
choisissez publiquement une des deux
équipes ça veut dire que vous avez peur
de l'autre donc si la France dit par
exemple je préfère jouer le Portugal
vous avez peur des Marocains
qui fonctionnent jamais voilà c'est ça
on fait le calcul à la fin on se fait
tôler par quelqu'un qui est supposé plus
faible du faible etc des failli être le
cas avec d'ailleurs la Croatie on s'en
souvient une victoire
arrachée face aux Croates ce sera en
tout cas à suivre l'autre match celui
qui nous intéresse aussi qui concerne la
France et l'Angleterre qui sera à suivre
ce samedi on imagine que ça va être là
aussi de voisinage historique
conflictualité c'est bien c'est c'est
dommage qu'ils pas France Russie parce
qu'on pourrait parler des oligarques qui
sont liés des villas et leur maison on
peut dire que de ce point de vue là les
Allemands quand même nous manque
beaucoup nos Français c'est bon on a une
autre période après on a réglé le
problème donc c'était bien à l'Europe
allemande est toujours intéressant de
manière ou d'une autre
autre sujet du jour moins moins riant
comme actualité évidemment c'est
l'Ukraine longtemps vulnérable dans les
airs est-elle en train de rééquilibrer
là aussi le rapport de force avec la
Russie comme elle l'a fait semble-t-il
déjà au niveau des du combat du combat
de terre avec l'infanterie en tout cas
Moscou accuse l'armée ukrainienne
d'avoir coup sur coup bombardé la zone
prorus de Donetsk dans le don-basse tu
en six personnes et d'avoir frappé
également trois bases en territoire
russe au moyen de drone écouter le
porte-parole du ministère russe de la
Défense
ont été interceptés par les forces
russes la chute et les débris dues à
leur explosion ont endommagé légèrement
la carlingue de deux avions sur les
pistes trois techniciens militaires qui
étaient présents sur le tarmac ont été
tués
à l'aérodrome de course qui a été touché
aujourd'hui après donc déjà deux hier on
est sur Gauthier que c'est la l'oeuvre
des Ukrainiens
le précédent avec le site qui était
tombé en territoire polonais invite à la
prudence Crimée dont on a toujours
aucune certitude non c'est vrai mais
enfin disons que autant
les missiles en territoire polonais du
point de vue de l'intention pouvait être
trouble on pouvait douter de de
l'authenticité de la preuve ukrainienne
ou bref il y avait une sorte
d’unanimisme au départ sur la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est le fait un
pour les Ukrainiens me semble-t-il de
d'indiquer que ils sont capables de
mettre à pas à genoux mais en de prendre
à défaut la défense anti-aérienne russe
de montrer qu'ils sont capables
d'atteindre des appareils russes de
montrer aussi qu'ils sont capables
d'atteindre en profondeur mais au-delà
de ça et je pense que c'est
l'origine de la victoire ou plutôt de la
visite de Zelinski dans le dans le don
de base c'est de dire l'option militaire
dont les Occidentaux semblent vouloir de
plus en plus s'affranchir cette option
militaire elle est plus que jamais
d'actualité pour une raison très simple
c'est que là où même les généraux qui
vous disent l'option diplomatique c'est
ce qu'il faut maintenant le militaire ça
ne gagne jamais et bien c'est
précisément ceux qui ne pensent pas à la
manière dont dénégociations aujourd'hui
pourrait tourner c'est-à-dire dans la
validation dans le fait d'entériner
l'action initiale du Kremlin et donc les
territoires décrétés comme la Russie ça
change la donne j'ai hâte de voir
effectivement si et encore une fois
c'est vérifié l'Ukraine pouvoir toucher
atteint des cibles en territoire russe
ça change la donne enfin
ces spectaculaire là parce que c'est
très en profondeur je crois que c'est
700 km donc ça c'est deux c'est deux
conclusions la première c'est qu'ils
sont capables de le faire et la deuxième
c'est que les Russes sont pas capables
de l'arrêter ce qui est révélateur la
deuxième chose c'est que c'est drone
sont en train de devenir mais on l'avait
vu avec le conflit Azerbaïdjan
Arménie on le voit dans un certain
nombre de conflits ces armes légères
assez sophistiquées mais assez
indétectable et puis pas très cher
finalement peuvent bouleverser un
équilibre militaire traditionnel avec
missile avion bombardier etc
donc là ça joue après je pense que pour
les Ukrainiens il s'agit je suis pas
dans je suis pas dans le secret de
l'état-major mais il s'agit de montrer
que pour le moment il est pas question
de renoncer au combat et qu'on est prêt
à prendre des risques et aller loin
qu'on est prêt même peut-être à se
mettre en désaccord avec les états
majeurs de l'OTAN qui pourraient penser
que etc donc c'est vraiment une volonté
nationale de mener la guerre de ne pas
abandonner de toucher des cibles
symboliques il y a eu cette attaque là
il y a eu le pont mais il me
rappelez-vous les drones maritimes là
qui ont touché semble-t-il des bateaux
non non
un peu plus tard dans le port dans le
port de port militaire de Crimée donc il
y a cette capacité à agir et nous on ne
renoncera pas et on tient cette guerre
malgré les bombardements que ça l'autre
chiffre intéressant de la semaine s'il
est vrai c'est le nombre de missiles
russes qui ont été abattus
lors des vagues d'attaque
sur les villes ukrainiennes et ça aussi
c'est un facteur important parce que ça
prouve qu'il y a une capacité de défense
bon malheureusement pas suffisante pour
faire zéro zéro dégât zéro mort mais
quand même ça ça limite ça limite cette
stratégie de la du bombardement urbain
sur les infrastructures électriques
énergétiques etc
que tient à mené la Russie pour
équilibrer le rapport de force merci
j'ai dit merci gauthierry binski c'était
ton va plus loin rester avec nous on se
retrouve un peu plus de 3 minutes pour
un nouveau journal
[Musique]